This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. This past fall, 200 people gathered at the Explorers Club in New York City. The building was once a clubhouse to famed naturalists and explorers. Now it's an archive of ephemera and rarities from pioneering expeditions, from treks to the world's tallest mountains, the North Pole, and the Moon. Woolly mammoth tusks frame a fireplace. A menacing polar bear towers near the landing with claws at the ready. And a cheetah, rumored to have been shot by Teddy Roosevelt, sits on a plinth just upstairs. The gathering was in honor of a new expedition. One in search, not of a single animal, but of thousands.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。去年秋天，200人聚集在纽约市的探险家俱乐部。这座建筑曾是著名博物学家和探险家的俱乐部会所。如今，它成了先驱探险队留下的珍稀遗物和档案库，从世界最高峰的跋涉到北极和月球的探索，应有尽有。猛犸象牙装饰着壁炉。一只极具威胁性的北极熊在楼梯平台附近昂首挺立，利爪蓄势待发。楼上一座底座上还蹲着一只猎豹，据传是西奥多·罗斯福亲手射杀的。这次聚会是为了纪念一次新的探险。这次探险寻找的不是某种单一的动物，而是成千上万只。
The club was hosting a biological census. An ecological survey so difficult, so complicated, so taxing, that it had never been attempted before. And may never be attempted again. It is a really big project. Like, I don't think we've ever been involved in a project of this scope in our lives. It's like moving a small little army around. This is Jamie Allen. The census was his idea,
俱乐部正在进行一项生物普查。这是一项生态调查，由于太困难、太复杂、太繁重，以前从未有人尝试过。而且可能永远不会再有人尝试。这确实是一个大项目。我觉得我们这辈子从未参与过如此规模的项目。这就像是在调动一支小军队。这是杰米·艾伦。普查是他的主意，
and when he started, it was a small operation. But now Jamie is merely the tip of a vast pyramid of census-related personnel, including a logistics chief, a chief cartographer, a veterinarian, an epidemiologist, a specialist from the Fish and Wildlife Service, and of course, a web team. And that's just the core staff. Below them are the foot soldiers, the volunteers who must go out into the field and do the actual counting. 300 plus volunteers counting 700 hectares, 100 meter by 100 meter, and 3,000 plus sheets
当他刚开始时，这只是一个小规模行动。但现在，杰米仅仅是庞大的普查相关人员金字塔的顶端，其中包括后勤主管、首席制图师、兽医、流行病学家、鱼类及野生动物管理局的专家，当然还有网络团队。这还只是核心员工。在他们之下是基层士兵，即必须深入实地进行实际清点的志愿者。300多名志愿者清点700公顷土地，每100米乘100米，还有3000多张
of paper that we have to, it's, yeah. A vast filing system, multiple offices, and a team of hundreds, all for the sake of answering one question. I want to know how many squirrels are in Central Park. Squirrels. They're counting squirrels. Date, October 14th, 2018. Time, 5...26. On a chilly Sunday evening, I'm following Stu, one of the Central Park Census volunteers,
纸，我们必须……是的。一个庞大的归档系统、多个办公室和一个数百人的团队，这一切都是为了回答一个问题。我想知道中央公园里有多少只松鼠。松鼠。他们在清点松鼠。日期，2018年10月14日。时间，5点26分。在一个寒冷的周日傍晚，我跟着斯图，中央公园普查的志愿者之一，
around the park's northern end. We're on the hunt for eastern grey squirrels, which is like the squirrel. It's what you'll find in just about any American city, but especially Central Park. So we need to be on this path down here. Okay. How do we get in there? Well, I'm gonna... I'll pretend you're not here, right? I just keep doing it? Yeah, yeah.
绕着公园北端走。我们正在寻找东部灰松鼠，也就是那种典型的松鼠。你在几乎任何美国城市都能见到它，但在中央公园尤其多。所以我们需要走这条小路。好的。我们怎么进去？嗯，我会……我会假装你不在，对吧？我继续做我的事？是的，是的。
Following his lead, we head off the path over fences and through tall brush. My face is gonna be covered in poison ivies too. Oh god, without a doubt. We're slowly making our way to his designated area, Hechtair 38E. Hechtairs are plots of land that measure a little less than two and a half acres each. The job of a census volunteer is to count all the squirrels they can find within their assigned hectares
跟着他的指引，我们离开小路，翻过栅栏，穿过高高的灌木丛。我的脸上肯定也会沾满毒藤。哦天哪，毫无疑问。我们正慢慢走向他指定的区域，第38E公顷。公顷是土地划分单位，每块面积略小于2.5英亩。普查志愿者的工作是清点他们所分配公顷内能找到的所有松鼠，
and only their assigned hectares. Although this doesn't stop Stu from getting incredibly excited by every squirrel he sees. Oh look, there's a squirrel. Can't count you buddy, you're not in my hectare. Go on, back, see you later. Oh look, there's a squirrel. I can't count you buddy, you're not in my hectare. Go on, back. See you later.
而且只能清点他们分配的公顷。尽管这并没有阻止斯图对看到的每一只松鼠都感到无比兴奋。哦看，那儿有一只松鼠。不能算你，伙计，你不在我的公顷范围内。走吧，回去，回头见。哦看，那儿有一只松鼠。我不能算你，伙计，你不在我的公顷范围内。走吧，回去。回头见。
After every hectare in the park has been surveyed, all the data will get plugged into a wildlife counting formula popularized by the great mid-century Danish-American squirrel biologist, von Flieger. The formula will account for squirrels that were double counted and ones no one managed to find, and then finally spit out a number that the world has been waiting for. The squirrel abundance number. The total population of eastern gray squirrels in Central Park. Give or take. At which point you would be totally justified in asking, as many do, what precisely is the
在公园里的每一公顷土地都被调查后，所有数据将被输入到一个由20世纪中叶伟大的丹麦裔美国松鼠生物学家冯·弗利格推广的野生动物清点公式中。该公式将计算出被重复清点的松鼠和没人能找到的松鼠，然后最终得出一个全世界都在等待的数字。松鼠丰度数值。中央公园东部灰松鼠的总种群数量。大概如此。此时，你完全有理由像许多人一样问，到底
point in knowing the squirrel abundance number? What they're saying is like you're counting squirrels, like squirrels have a specific context in people's minds and it's to be ignored. Like it's assumed I think that because they're so common we know everything we need to know about squirrels, but the opposite is true. The very fact that no one has bothered to do a Central Park Squirrel Census before to gather this most basic of data points about one of the most common animals in our landscape reveals a kind of societal blind spot we have in regard to squirrels. For a long time now, we've taken them for granted, including the story of where all
知道松鼠丰度数值有什么意义？他们说的是，你正在清点松鼠，松鼠在人们心中有特定的语境，而这被忽视了。我想人们认为因为它们太常见了，所以我们已经了解了关于松鼠所需的一切，但事实恰恰相反。事实上，此前从未有人费心进行过中央公园松鼠普查，以收集关于我们景观中最常见动物之一的最基本数据点，这揭示了我们在松鼠问题上的一种社会盲点。长期以来，我们一直认为它们理所当然，包括关于所有
these squirrels came from. The squirrels we see in our cities and towns are so everyday, so ubiquitous, so just there, that it's easy to assume they've always been there. But the truth is, they haven't. Mid-19th century, you could walk through a place like Boston or Philadelphia or Manhattan, and you would not see a single squirrel. This is Etienne Benson. He's a historian of environmental science at the University of Pennsylvania. And he says the cities of the early 19th century were effectively squirreless.
这些松鼠从何而来的故事。我们在城市和城镇中看到的松鼠是如此日常、如此普遍、如此“就在那里”，以至于很容易认为它们一直都在那里。但事实是，它们并没有。19世纪中叶，你走在波士顿、费城或曼哈顿这样的地方，你一只松鼠也看不到。这是艾蒂安·本森。他是宾夕法尼亚大学的环境科学历史学家。他说19世纪早期的城市实际上是没有松鼠的。
These were animals you could only see if you left the city. And then even perhaps left the farm, right, and went deep into the woods. And it was only when you went deep into the woods that you would have the chance to see something like a squirrel. In fact, squirrels were considered so elusive that the very wealthy liked to keep them as exotic pets. In 1856, an article in the New York Times described how one such pet escaped from its owner's home in Manhattan, and when it was discovered in a tree, a crowd of people gathered
这些动物只有当你离开城市时才能看到。甚至可能还要离开农场，深入森林。只有当你深入森林时，才有机会看到像松鼠这样的东西。事实上，松鼠被认为非常难以捉摸，以至于非常富有的人喜欢把它们当作异国宠物来养。1856年，《纽约时报》的一篇文章描述了一只这样的宠物如何从曼哈顿主人的家中逃脱，当它在树上被发现时，一群人聚集起来，
in amazement trying to lure it down. Eventually the crowd grew so large and rowdy that the police had to forcibly disperse it. So how did these eastern gray squirrels, these reclusive woodland creatures, make their way into our urban spaces. Well, for starters, says Etienne, they didn't. At least not on their own. What was so fascinating to me was to find out that they had been intentionally introduced. The squirrels that we all take for granted as we walk through the park or on our way
惊奇地试图引诱它下来。最终人群变得如此庞大和吵闹，以至于警察不得不强行驱散他们。那么，这些东部灰松鼠，这些隐居的林地生物，是如何进入我们的城市空间的呢？嗯，首先，艾蒂安说，它们并没有。至少不是靠它们自己。让我着迷的是发现它们是被有意引入的。我们走在公园里或去
to the gym or the office are only there because we put them there. They were deliberately brought into cities and fed and sheltered. The first city that we know of to introduce squirrels was Philadelphia in 1847. Like many East Coast cities of the mid-19th century, it was already a highly urban environment. People yearned for a taste of the wilderness
健身房或办公室路上所认为理所当然的松鼠，只是因为我们把它们放在了那里。它们被蓄意带入城市，并得到喂养和庇护。我们所知第一个引入松鼠的城市是1847年的费城。像19世纪中叶的许多东海岸城市一样，它已经是一个高度城市化的环境。人们渴望体验荒野，
that the squirrel was seen to embody. They were captured in the wilderness, brought into the city, and placed on a single tree, almost as if they were animals in a menagerie or a zoo. The tree was in the middle of a small public square, and it was equipped with a wooden shelter and a fence so the squirrels could stay safe from the elements and any would-be predators in their little squirrel home.
而松鼠被视为荒野的化身。它们在荒野中被捕获，带入城市，并被安置在一棵树上，几乎就像动物园里的动物一样。那棵树位于一个小公共广场的中央，并配有一个木制避难所和栅栏，这样松鼠就可以在它们的小松鼠家中免受风雨和任何潜在捕食者的伤害。
A few other cities like Boston replicated this model. And at first the number of squirrels was teeny tiny. Philadelphia started out with only three. Think of it as a trial run. Only this first trial run? It went terribly. When I started working on this topic, I thought, okay, you introduce a few squirrels into an urban park, in a few years you're going to have thousands of squirrels, no problem.
波士顿等其他一些城市也复制了这种模式。起初，松鼠的数量非常少。费城最初只有三只。把它看作是一次试运行。只是这第一次试运行？结果非常糟糕。当我开始研究这个课题时，我想，好吧，你在城市公园里引入几只松鼠，几年后你就会有成千上万只松鼠，没问题。
But at the very beginning, they were essentially incapable of surviving. The cities of the 19th century just didn't have the kind of large parks and extensive tree cover we see today. When you thought about urban landscapes, they were very unfriendly to an animal that required trees for food. In the classic storybook image of a squirrel, it's always clutching an acorn. And that's basically true. A wild squirrel requires deciduous nut-bearing plants such as oak trees in order to survive. Without trees, the city had to
但在最开始，它们基本上无法生存。19世纪的城市根本没有我们今天看到的那种大型公园和广泛的树木覆盖。当你想到城市景观时，它们对需要树木作为食物的动物非常不友好。在松鼠的经典故事书形象中，它总是抓着一颗橡子。这基本上是真的。野生松鼠需要落叶坚果类植物（如橡树）才能生存。没有树木，城市必须
provide for the squirrels. But the squirrel feed often proved to be either insufficient or nutritionally worthless. So those first squirrels either But the squirrel feed often proved to be either insufficient or nutritionally worthless. So those first squirrels either died off, were killed, or were adopted as pets. – In 1855, a reporter for the Boston Evening Transcript described the introduction of squirrels as, quote, an absurd and reprehensible experiment. All of which raises a question. – Why are there now squirrels everywhere in American cities? reprehensible experiment, all of which raises a question. Why are there now squirrels everywhere in American cities? I think it's more a model of if you build it, they will come.
为松鼠提供食物。但松鼠饲料往往被证明要么不足，要么毫无营养价值。所以那些第一批松鼠要么死掉、被杀，要么被当作宠物领养。——1855年，《波士顿晚间誊本》的一位记者将引入松鼠描述为“一个荒谬且应受谴责的实验”。所有这些都提出了一个问题。——为什么现在美国城市里到处都是松鼠？应受谴责的实验，所有这些都提出了一个问题。为什么现在美国城市里到处都是松鼠？我认为这更像是一个“如果你建造它，它们就会来”的模式。
Gabriel Willow is a naturalist who specializes in animal species that live in urban environments. So I study nature and educate people about the natural world, specifically in New York City. And he says that in the late 19th century, green spaces like New York's were undergoing a transformation. Areas of open land, once multi-purpose fields used for everything from cattle grazing to slaughterhouses and militia training,
加布里埃尔·威洛是一位专门研究城市环境中动物物种的博物学家。所以我研究自然并向人们普及自然世界，特别是在纽约市。他说，在19世纪末，像纽约这样的绿地正在经历一场变革。曾经是多用途田地的开阔土地，被用于从牛群放牧到屠宰场和民兵训练的各种用途，
were being transformed into spaces of leisure. And by the 1870s, city dwellers were leaving behind small, busy squares in favor of large, idyllic parks. And although they were designed for people, these new urban oases just might be the best thing to ever happen to the eastern gray squirrel. Because the parks weren't just big, they were also designed to mimic the natural world. Take Central Park and Prospect
正在被改造成休闲空间。到了1870年代，城市居民开始抛弃繁忙的小广场，转而青睐大型、田园诗般的公园。虽然它们是为人类设计的，但这些新的城市绿洲可能是有史以来发生在东部灰松鼠身上最好的事情。因为这些公园不仅大，而且设计初衷就是为了模仿自然世界。以中央公园和展望
Park in New York, for example, both designed by Calvert Vox and Frederick Law Olmsted. They were working with the existing geology and hydrology. They took naturally existing small ponds or marshy areas and made lakes out of them. They also chose to keep the area's dramatic rocky outcroppings instead of blasting them away, as had been done with the rest of the city's grid. And so they were working with certain natural elements. These natural parks were filled with hedges and lakes and streams and lots and lots of trees, including to the great fortune of squirrels everywhere, oak trees. Red oak is very common, white oak is very common, pin oak is very common. There's
公园为例，它们都是由卡尔弗特·沃克斯和弗雷德里克·劳·奥姆斯特德设计的。他们利用了现有的地质和水文条件。他们将自然存在的小池塘或沼泽地变成了湖泊。他们还选择保留该地区引人注目的岩石露头，而不是像城市其他网格区域那样将其炸毁。因此，他们是在利用某些自然元素。这些自然公园里种满了树篱、湖泊、溪流和大量的树木，包括让各地松鼠感到万分幸运的橡树。红橡树很常见，白橡树很常见，针橡树很常见。有
a lot of acorns around. Everything a would-be squirrel resident might want or need. And it was in this oak dotted acorn strewn landscape in Central Park in 1877 that a handful of eastern gray squirrels were introduced for a second trial run. And it was in that landscape that these squirrels virtually exploded in population. By the turn of the century, what had started as just a few dozen squirrels now numbered in the, actually this is around the time that people just stopped counting. I mean, how could you?
很多橡子。准松鼠居民可能想要或需要的一切。正是在1877年中央公园这片橡树点缀、橡子遍地的景观中，少数东部灰松鼠被引入进行了第二次试运行。正是在那片景观中，这些松鼠的数量几乎呈爆炸式增长。到了世纪之交，最初只有几十只的松鼠现在数量已经达到……实际上，大约就在这个时候，人们停止了清点。我的意思是，怎么可能清点得过来？
With so many squirrels running around, guesses range from the high hundreds to over 5,000. In Central Park and beyond, squirrels became as commonplace as fire hydrants and telephone poles and all the other newfound accessories of the urban landscape. And as this new approach to urban parkland spread to other cities, so did the idea of populating them with squirrels. Eastern gray squirrels were introduced again to places like Philadelphia and Boston and West Coast cities like Seattle, Vancouver, and San Francisco.
随着这么多松鼠到处乱跑，猜测范围从几百只到超过5000只不等。在中央公园及其他地方，松鼠变得像消防栓、电线杆以及城市景观中所有其他新发现的附属物一样司空见惯。随着这种城市公园建设方法传播到其他城市，用松鼠填充它们的想法也随之传播开来。东部灰松鼠再次被引入费城、波士顿以及西雅图、温哥华和旧金山等西海岸城市。
Eastern grays were also introduced overseas to England, Italy, and South Africa. And it wasn't just the oak trees in these newly lush environments that were providing sustenance for the squirrels. At the time, people considered it their moral duty to feed them. Up until the early 20th century, the dominant way of understanding the proper relationship between humans and animals in the city is centered on charity.
东部灰松鼠也被引入海外的英国、意大利和南非。在这些新近郁郁葱葱的环境中，不仅橡树为松鼠提供了食物。当时，人们认为喂养它们是自己的道德义务。直到20世纪初，理解城市中人类与动物之间适当关系的主导方式是以慈善为中心的。
It's centered on the idea that humans have an obligation, a responsibility, to create a friendly, welcoming environment for certain kinds of animals to flourish. The ideal city was one that provided a home for good animals and banished the bad. So if you go back even and read like John James Audubon's account of bird species, he might talk about the bloodthirsty hawk or the wily raven. And so people used to shoot hawks and falcons and eagles and other birds of prey because they're predators, because they would eat other animals, people thought, oh, they're just mean. Whereas other animals like pigeons and of course squirrels were considered peaceful.
它以人类有义务、有责任为某些动物的繁荣创造一个友好、欢迎的环境这一理念为中心。理想的城市是为好动物提供家园并驱逐坏动物的城市。所以如果你回去读约翰·詹姆斯·奥杜邦关于鸟类的记述，他可能会谈到嗜血的鹰或狡猾的乌鸦。因此，人们过去常常射杀鹰、猎鹰、雕和其他猛禽，因为它们是捕食者，因为它们会吃其他动物，人们认为，哦，它们只是卑劣的。而鸽子，当然还有松鼠，则被认为是和平的。
More than that, they interacted with humans. The sight of an undomesticated animal not only approaching you, but effectively communicating with you by soliciting food, was a sign of its civilized nature. So it was only proper that you should feed them. Historians would later give these wild animals and the residents who brought them into the city a name, the more than human community. So the idea was to create a kind of, you might even call it a kind of fantasy world in which every animal that is in the city is living peacefully with the others at the indulgence of the humans that
不仅如此，它们还与人类互动。看到一种未驯化的动物不仅接近你，而且通过索要食物有效地与你交流，这是它文明天性的标志。所以喂养它们是理所当然的。历史学家后来给这些野生动物以及将它们带入城市的居民起了一个名字：超人类社区。所以这个想法是创造一种，你甚至可以称之为一种幻想世界，在这个世界里，城市里的每一种动物都在人类的宽容下与其他动物和平共处，而人类则
run the place. Thanks to the more than human community model, urban squirrels lived large for decades. Nuts, trees, and humans feeding them extra food and killing off all their predators. They had it made. And in the case of New Haven, for example, there's even an article that I found that describes them as becoming so obese that they began to fall from the trees. As the 19th century led into the 20th, and the squirrels were busy spreading out into suburban attics and college campuses, no one stopped to wonder if there could be such a
管理着这个地方。多亏了超人类社区模式，城市松鼠几十年来过着优越的生活。坚果、树木，还有人类喂养它们额外的食物并消灭了它们所有的捕食者。它们过得太舒服了。以纽黑文为例，我甚至发现了一篇文章，描述它们变得如此肥胖，以至于开始从树上掉下来。随着19世纪进入20世纪，松鼠忙着扩散到郊区的阁楼和大学校园，没有人停下来思考是否会有
thing as too many squirrels. But as hard as it is to admit, there is now evidence to suggest there might actually be too many. There is an ongoing attack against the power grid and it's being led by squirrels. Matthew Harper is an information security expert with 20 years of experience, and he says when it comes to threats to the U.S. power network, forget terrorism, forget Russian hackers. In the case of the utility infrastructure,
“松鼠太多”这种情况。但尽管很难承认，现在有证据表明可能确实太多了。目前正发生着一场针对电网的攻击，而带头的就是松鼠。马修·哈珀是一位拥有20年经验的信息安全专家，他说，当谈到对美国电力网络的威胁时，忘了恐怖主义，忘了俄罗斯黑客。在公用事业基础设施方面，
it's the humble squirrel that's causing most of the issues. By some estimates, one out of every five power outages in the United States are squirrel-related. To be fair to the squirrels, they really start out with the best of intentions. Squirrels need to build nests, and they usually build those nests in trees. But they also build them in anything that looks like a tree,
是卑微的松鼠造成了大部分问题。据估计，美国五分之一的停电事故与松鼠有关。公平地说，松鼠最初确实是出于好意。松鼠需要筑巢，它们通常在树上筑巢。但它们也会在任何看起来像树的东西上筑巢，
like utility poles or transformers. And like all rodents, a squirrel's incisor teeth never stop growing, so they have to chew to keep them filed down. They mostly chew bark and branches and nuts, but they also chew things like power cables. So inevitably, some unlucky squirrel will gnaw through the insulation of a power line
比如电线杆或变压器。像所有啮齿动物一样，松鼠的门牙永远不会停止生长，所以它们必须通过啃咬来磨短牙齿。它们主要啃咬树皮、树枝和坚果，但它们也会啃咬电缆之类的东西。因此，不可避免地，一些倒霉的松鼠会咬穿电线的绝缘层，
or step on two exposed wires at the same time and... Oh. Killing the squirrel and shorting the system. To keep track of all those system shorts, Matthew runs a website called Cyber Squirrel One. Which is a website which tracks squirrel activities and attacks against the power grid. And yes, this is real. Cyber Squirrel One consists of a big map marking the largest power outages caused by squirrels
或者同时踩在两根裸露的电线上，然后……哦。杀死了松鼠并导致系统短路。为了跟踪所有这些系统短路，马修运营着一个名为“网络松鼠一号”的网站。这是一个跟踪松鼠活动和针对电网攻击的网站。是的，这是真的。“网络松鼠一号”由一张大地图组成，标记了过去30年里由松鼠造成的最大规模停电。
in the past 30 years. Pick a year and you can find hundreds of pins indicating squirrel incidents, splayed out across the lower 48 in Canada. There's a drop down menu if you want to see outages caused by other animals, but don't bother. When it comes to power problems, it's mostly just squirrels. Can you give me some examples of squirrel-related power outages? Alright, I'm just pulling it up now. Squirrel, here we go.
选一个年份，你就能找到数百个标示松鼠事件的图钉，散布在美国本土48州和加拿大。如果你想查看由其他动物造成的停电，有一个下拉菜单，但别费心了。当谈到电力问题时，大部分都是松鼠。你能给我举一些与松鼠相关的停电例子吗？好的，我正在调取数据。松鼠，来了。
Last year, 2018, a college in California actually ended up having to cancel classes. Then in November of 2018, a single roving squirrel knocked out three substations in upstate New York, causing a string of power outages for more than 12,000 people. That same month, another squirrel took out a polling station in Virginia on the day of the presidential election. Then, in December, a squirrel cut the power of an entire shopping mall in South Carolina one week before Christmas.
去年，2018年，加州的一所大学实际上不得不取消课程。然后在2018年11月，一只流浪松鼠摧毁了纽约州北部的三个变电站，导致超过12000人停电。同月，另一只松鼠在总统选举当天摧毁了弗吉尼亚州的一个投票站。然后，在12月，一只松鼠在圣诞节前一周切断了南卡罗来纳州整个购物中心的电力。
A particular case in Canada back in April 2009 impacted 55,000 people. — And those are just the big ones. In Austin, Texas, squirrels were responsible for over 400 separate outages in 2015 alone. — But the greatest rodent-related outage of all occurred in December of 1987, in the last place you'd ever expect to find an electrocuted squirrel. That story and more after this. [♪ music playing, drum beat playing, drum beat playing, drum beat playing, drum beat playing, drum beat playing, drum beat playing, drum beat playing, drum beat playing, drum beat playing, drum beat playing, drum beat playing, drum beat playing, drum beat playing, drum beat playing, drum beat playing, drum beat playing, drum beat playing, drum beat playing, drum beat playing, drum beat playing, drum beat playing, drum beat playing, drum beat playing, drum beat playing, drum beat playing, drum beat playing, drum beat playing, drum beat playing, drum beat playing, drum beat playing, drum beat playing, drum beat playing, drum beat playing, drum beat playing, drum beat playing, drum beat playing, drum beat playing, drum beat playing, drum beat playing, drum beat playing, drum beat playing, drum beat playing, drum beat playing, drum beat playing, drum beat playing, drum beat playing, drum beat playing, drum beat playing, drum beat playing, drum beat playing, drum beat playing, drum beat playing, drum beat playing, drum beat playing, drum beat playing, drum beat playing, drum beat playing, drum beat playing, drum beat playing, drum beat playing, drum beat playing, drum beat playing, drum beat playing, drum beat playing, drum beat playing, drum beat playing, drum beat playing, drum beat playing, drum beat playing, drum beat playing, drum beat playing, drum beat playing, drum beat playing, drum beat playing, drum beat playing, drum beat playing, drum beat playing, drum beat playing, drum beat playing, drum beat playing, drum beat playing, drum beat playing, drum beat playing, drum beat playing, drum beat playing, drum beat playing, drum beat playing, drum beat playing, drum beat playing, drum beat playing, drum beat playing, drum beat playing, drum beat playing, drum beat playing, drum beat playing, drum beat playing, drum beat playing, drum beat playing, drum beat playing, drum beat playing, drum beat playing It happened on December 9th, 1987. It's kind of sad for me because I am a true animal lover.
2009年4月在加拿大发生的一个特殊案例影响了55000人。——而这些还只是大事件。仅在2015年，德克萨斯州奥斯汀市的松鼠就造成了超过400起单独的停电事故。——但最严重的啮齿动物相关停电发生在1987年12月，在你想不到会发现触电松鼠的最后一个地方。那个故事以及更多内容，稍后继续。[♪ 音乐播放，鼓点播放...] 事情发生在1987年12月9日。这对我来说有点难过，因为我是一个真正的动物爱好者。
Joseph Sangiamino is a retired member of the New York Stock Exchange. That means he used to be one of those guys you'd see yelling and screaming on the trading room floor. And it's simply this. Back in the day, you know, back in 1987, the New York Stock Exchange was everything to the world. Back then in the 80s, the exchange controlled 85% of the global stock market. And so traders like Joe, they were the kings of Wall Street. We were the place to go. We were so proud to wear our white badges with our numbers on it and say we worked on the floor of the New York Stock Exchange. But there was also another exchange in town
约瑟夫·桑贾米诺是纽约证券交易所的一名退休成员。这意味着他曾经是你在交易大厅里看到的那种大喊大叫的人之一。原因很简单。在过去，你知道，在1987年，纽约证券交易所对世界来说就是一切。那时在80年代，交易所控制着全球85%的股票市场。所以像乔这样的交易员，他们是华尔街的国王。我们是人们要去的地方。我们非常自豪地戴着带有编号的白色徽章，说我们在纽约证券交易所的大厅工作。但城里还有另一个交易所，
that was slowly chipping away at their market share, their biggest rival, NASDAQ. The NASDAQ was an automated exchange that ran on computers. It didn't need floor traders. And the traders at the New York Stock Exchange, who made trades in person by hand, hated it. So Joe still remembers the glorious day a rumor began to spread among the 4,000 traders on the floor of the exchange.
正在慢慢蚕食他们的市场份额，他们最大的竞争对手，纳斯达克。纳斯达克是一个在计算机上运行的自动化交易所。它不需要大厅交易员。而纽约证券交易所的交易员，他们通过人工面对面进行交易，对此恨之入骨。所以乔仍然记得那个谣言开始在交易所大厅的4000名交易员中传播的光荣日子。
We start hearing that NASDAQ just had a technical glitch. And by the time it got from one end to the exchange to the other, it might've took about 30 seconds and it just word of mouth, it just flies. Finally, the electronic ticker tape, scrawling along one of the walls of the exchange, lit up with the news. And the ticker tape, the ticker tape was just flying across and we knew.
我们开始听说纳斯达克刚刚出现了技术故障。从交易所的一端传到另一端，可能只花了大约30秒，这只是口口相传，传播速度极快。最后，沿着交易所墙壁之一滚动的电子行情显示屏亮起了这条新闻。行情显示屏，行情显示屏就在上面飞快滚动，我们知道了。
Their deepest, darkest wish had come true. NASDAQ had failed. It was really a magn—it was a dream. And the trading floor erupted. I mean, you could—it was deafening. For 82 minutes on December 9, 1987, NASDAQ was offline, losing an estimated 20 million trades. And then we find out that it was a squirrel. A squirrel had chewed through a power line in Connecticut
他们内心深处最黑暗的愿望实现了。纳斯达克失败了。这真是一个……这是一个梦想。交易大厅沸腾了。我的意思是，你可以……震耳欲聋。1987年12月9日，纳斯达克离线了82分钟，估计损失了2000万笔交易。然后我们发现是一只松鼠。一只松鼠咬断了康涅狄格州的一根电线，
where NASDAQ drew its electricity, but it did not affect the New York Stock Exchange, much to the everlasting joy of traders like Joseph Sangiomino. To NASDAQ, that squirrel, that squirrel was Godzilla. To us on the New York Stock Exchange, that little squirrel was Superman. Because for 80 minutes, we were the kings again. And unfortunately, the squirrel paid the ultimate price for our few hours of glory that particular
纳斯达克从那里获取电力，但这并没有影响纽约证券交易所，这让像约瑟夫·桑贾米诺这样的交易员感到无比快乐。对纳斯达克来说，那只松鼠，那只松鼠是哥斯拉。对我们纽约证券交易所来说，那只小松鼠是超人。因为在那80分钟里，我们又成了国王。不幸的是，那只松鼠为我们那天的几个小时荣耀付出了最终的代价。
day. America's squirrels have also been wreaking havoc overseas. In Great Britain, eastern grey squirrels introduced in 1876 quickly began to displace the native red squirrel, driving it to near extinction. And the eastern grey squirrel might be cute, but the red squirrel is super cute. To Google it is to love it.
美国的松鼠也在海外造成了严重破坏。在英国，1876年引入的东部灰松鼠很快开始排挤本地的红松鼠，将其推向灭绝边缘。东部灰松鼠可能很可爱，但红松鼠超级可爱。谷歌一下你就会爱上它。
And now there's only a few small pockets of red squirrels left in northern England and Scotland. This despite a massive eradication campaign to keep the American invaders out of the Scottish Highlands. In Europe, they're officially an invasive species. But even as American squirrels were taking out shopping malls and stock exchanges and invading foreign countries, the very things that had allowed them to proliferate in the first place were slowly being taken away.
现在，在英格兰北部和苏格兰只剩下少数几个红松鼠的小聚居区。尽管有大规模的根除运动来阻止美国入侵者进入苏格兰高地。在欧洲，它们被正式列为入侵物种。但即使美国松鼠正在摧毁购物中心和证券交易所并入侵外国，当初让它们得以繁衍的那些东西也正在慢慢被剥夺。
Starting in the mid-20th century, ecologists, wildlife managers, and park officials started to reexamine America's approach to wildlife. They began to argue that predators like coyotes and hawks should no longer be hunted for the sake of a more than human community. That starts to get replaced with a really different view, right? This ecological view in which we understand those relationships of predation as essential to the ecosystem as a whole. In this new ecological model, the ideal environment was no longer one
从20世纪中叶开始，生态学家、野生动物管理者和公园官员开始重新审视美国对待野生动物的方式。他们开始争论，像土狼和鹰这样的捕食者不应该再为了“超人类社区”的利益而被猎杀。这开始被一种非常不同的观点所取代，对吧？这种生态观点认为，我们将捕食关系理解为整个生态系统不可或缺的一部分。在这种新的生态模式中，理想的环境不再是
that corresponded to notions of civilized versus uncivilized species, but one in which a variety of species, predator and prey alike, maintained a natural population balance with only minimal human intervention. It took a few decades for this idea to spread from the national parks into the cities, but by the 1980s it had arrived, along into the cities. But by the 1980s, it had arrived along with the predators. Which for an ecologically minded naturalist like Gabriel Willow is a wonderful thing. The coyotes are coming back on their own. We're not bringing them back. Ravens, ravens
与文明与非文明物种概念相对应的环境，而是一个各种物种（无论是捕食者还是猎物）在极少人为干预的情况下保持自然种群平衡的环境。这个想法从国家公园传播到城市花了几年时间，但到了1980年代，它已经到来，并伴随着捕食者。对于像加布里埃尔·威洛这样具有生态意识的博物学家来说，这是一件美妙的事情。土狼正在自己回来。我们没有把它们带回来。乌鸦，乌鸦
are nesting in New York City within the last 15 years. We did not reintroduce them. The red-tailed hawk came back of its own accord. Other species we intentionally reintroduced like peregrine falcons and they're thriving. New York City has the highest population density of peregrine falcons in the world. For most of us the death of a few squirrels seems like a small price to pay in exchange for this newfound biodiversity. Today there's no shortage of webcams set up by people who have discovered a hawk's nest outside their 12th floor apartment window. And while we've been busy welcoming the squirrels predators back into our cities we've
在过去15年里开始在纽约市筑巢。我们没有重新引入它们。红尾鵟是自己回来的。其他物种我们有意重新引入，比如游隼，它们正在茁壮成长。纽约市拥有世界上最高的游隼种群密度。对我们大多数人来说，牺牲几只松鼠似乎是换取这种新发现的生物多样性所付出的微小代价。今天，有很多人设置了网络摄像头，他们发现12楼公寓窗外有一个鹰巢。当我们忙着欢迎松鼠的捕食者回到我们的城市时，我们也
also begun to finally withdraw our charity. I think everybody should go check out squirrels they're pretty cool. I'm pro-squirrel, I'm team squirrel you know I just don't think we need to be feeding them. Gabriel and other naturalists think feeding squirrels has no place in the new ecological model. Providing bread and other unnatural foods can lead to a variety of health problems. And acclimating squirrels to hand-feeding can make them overly dependent on humans and possibly prone to unstable population booms, none of which is ultimately good for the squirrels or the larger environment. Which is why 142 years after welcoming
终于开始撤回我们的慈善。我认为每个人都应该去看看松鼠，它们很酷。我支持松鼠，我是松鼠队的，你知道，我只是认为我们不需要喂养它们。加布里埃尔和其他博物学家认为，在新的生态模式中，喂养松鼠没有立足之地。提供面包和其他非自然食物会导致各种健康问题。让松鼠习惯于手喂可能会使它们过度依赖人类，并可能导致不稳定的种群激增，这对松鼠或更大的环境最终都没有好处。这就是为什么在欢迎
squirrels into the fold of our more-than-human community, New York City is done given handouts. Good morning. Today is March 1st, 2019 and the time is 12.05. Welcome to Pelenford's Recreation Center. This past winter, the New York City Parks Department held a hearing for a proposed rule change that would make it illegal to feed any wild animal in the parks. This hearing is attended to solicit comments
松鼠进入我们的超人类社区142年后，纽约市不再提供施舍。早上好。今天是2019年3月1日，时间是12点05分。欢迎来到佩伦福德娱乐中心。去年冬天，纽约市公园管理局举行了一场听证会，讨论一项拟议的规则变更，该变更将使在公园内喂养任何野生动物成为非法。这次听证会旨在征求关于
regarding the proposed rule changes. These comments will become part of the public record. Gabriel Willow was there, too. Although it didn't go down quite the way he thought it would. I didn't really expect it to be quite as skewed as it was in terms of almost everybody there was speaking against the regulations. This criminal act that runs against the morals and rules of a civilized society. New York parks says that the squirrels, they should be squirrels, they should be animals
拟议规则变更的意见。这些意见将成为公共记录的一部分。加布里埃尔·威洛也在那里。虽然事情的发展并不完全像他想象的那样。我真的没想到它会如此一边倒，几乎所有在场的人都在反对这些规定。这种违背文明社会道德和规则的犯罪行为。纽约公园说松鼠应该是松鼠，它们应该是动物，
and forage like they do in the wild, except for one thing. The parks aren't the wild. I don't know that I've encountered that many squirrel and pigeon feeding fans in one place before. And although they agreed the animals should be eating healthy food, they were not buying into the ecological model. The parks are not nature. They're an artificial situation. We are part of their environment. You can't change that. When people expressed concern that certain animals in certain parks might starve,
并像在野外一样觅食，除了一件事。公园不是野外。我不知道我以前是否在同一个地方遇到过这么多松鼠和鸽子喂养爱好者。虽然他们同意动物应该吃健康的食物，但他们并不买账生态模式。公园不是自然。它们是一种人工环境。我们是它们环境的一部分。你无法改变这一点。当人们担心某些公园里的某些动物可能会饿死时，
Gabriel tried to stand up for the hands-off approach. The problem of them starving due to lack of food is because there's a higher population, because they're being fed. It's a cycle. But the applause was tepid. Thank you. It was not as poorly received as the founder and director of the Wild Bird Fund. She was also against feeding. We take the proposed amendment to the rule.
加布里埃尔试图支持不干预的方法。它们因缺乏食物而饿死的问题是因为种群数量较高，因为它们被喂养了。这是一个循环。但掌声很冷淡。谢谢。它并没有像野生鸟类基金会的创始人和主任那样受到冷遇。她也反对喂养。我们接受对该规则的拟议修正案。
She was actually booed. I'm sorry, I ran over. Boo! I'm sorry, I ran over. Exactly what effect the blanket ban would have on wildlife populations is unclear. But regardless of the ecological impact, the biggest takeaway from the hearing was that the concept of the more-than-human community that was still going strong. I'm here today as a voice for New York City's non-human residents because I see what's happening to our wildlife neighbors
她实际上被嘘了。对不起，我超时了。嘘！对不起，我超时了。全面禁令对野生动物种群到底会有什么影响尚不清楚。但无论生态影响如何，听证会最大的收获是，超人类社区的概念依然强劲。我今天在这里作为纽约市非人类居民的代言人，因为我看到我们的野生动物邻居正在发生的事情
as really truly tragic. The feeling that these animals are fellow citizens and should be treated with the same consideration has never fully gone away. It is not just about what we want. It's about what the squirrels and all of the other than human beings in our parks want too. And they are constituents of New York City. I go to the park every day.
确实非常悲惨。这些动物是我们的同胞，应该受到同样的对待，这种感觉从未完全消失。这不仅仅是关于我们想要什么。这是关于松鼠和我们公园里所有其他非人类生物想要什么。它们是纽约市的选民。我每天都去公园。
People love to feed the animals in the park. On any park bench in any city, you'll see people throwing crumbs to the birds, and the birds approaching for more. It's one way we feel a connection to nature. For just a moment, both human and animal are doing something together. That shared experience between species, that's what the people at the hearing didn't want taken away. Gabriel Willow also believes that there is value in connecting with these animals, but he sees it as a reason not to feed them.
人们喜欢喂公园里的动物。在任何城市的任何公园长椅上，你都会看到人们向鸟儿投掷面包屑，而鸟儿走近索要更多。这是我们感受与自然联系的一种方式。在那一刻，人类和动物都在一起做某事。物种之间那种共享的体验，就是听证会上的人们不想被剥夺的东西。加布里埃尔·威洛也认为与这些动物建立联系是有价值的，但他认为这正是不要喂养它们的原因。
I think people really crave a direct interaction and connection with nature. And so what I was saying when I spoke was like, look, please go to the park, observe wildlife, feel that connection. You don't need to touch them. You don't need to pet them. You don't need to hold them. You don't need to feed them. Like, it's actually more interesting and more valuable to stand back and see an
我认为人们确实渴望与自然进行直接的互动和联系。所以我发言时说的是，看，请去公园，观察野生动物，感受那种联系。你不需要触摸它们。你不需要抚摸它们。你不需要抱着它们。你不需要喂养它们。实际上，退后一步观察动物表现出更自然的
animal exhibiting a more natural behavior. Watch a squirrel long enough and you'll see it play tricks on other squirrels. If a squirrel carrying an acorn believes it's being watched, it will dig a hole, pantomime putting the acorn in the hole, and then cover the hole back up, all while hiding the real acorn in its mouth, just to throw its fellow squirrels off the scent. Squirrels have been seen carefully organizing their acorns by size and shape before they bury them.
行为，这更有趣、更有价值。观察松鼠足够久，你就会看到它对其他松鼠耍花招。如果一只带着橡子的松鼠认为自己被监视了，它会挖一个洞，假装把橡子放进洞里，然后把洞盖上，同时把真正的橡子藏在嘴里，只是为了把它的同伴引开。人们看到松鼠在埋藏橡子之前会仔细地按大小和形状整理它们。
Biologists believe it's a mnemonic device that helps the squirrels remember what they buried where. They have a specific call when they see a predator, so if you learn a little bit of squirrel language, like, I know the hawk call, so if I hear that I'll look up and often see a hawk. So for them to just sort of allow us to be there, but go about their day-to-day life is so much more powerful for me. There's more than one way to connect to the animals with whom we share our cities.
生物学家认为这是一种记忆辅助工具，可以帮助松鼠记住它们把什么埋在了哪里。它们在看到捕食者时有特定的叫声，所以如果你学习一点松鼠语言，比如，我知道鹰的叫声，所以如果我听到那个，我会抬头看，通常会看到一只鹰。所以让它们允许我们在那里，但继续过它们的日常生活，对我来说更有力量。与我们共享城市的动物建立联系的方式不止一种。
Whether it's listening to the yipping of coyotes in the middle of the night, setting up a webcam for the hawk nest outside your window, or counting all the squirrels in Central Park. In March, Jamie Allen and the other team members of the Squirrel Census finished gathering their data. They plan to reveal the squirrel abundance number in June. Etienne Benson says he doesn't know how many squirrels there are in Central Park, but he thinks he does understand why everyone is so eager to find out.
无论是听深夜里土狼的叫声，为窗外的鹰巢设置网络摄像头，还是清点中央公园里的所有松鼠。三月，杰米·艾伦和松鼠普查的其他团队成员完成了数据收集。他们计划在六月公布松鼠丰度数值。艾蒂安·本森说他不知道中央公园里有多少只松鼠，但他认为他明白为什么每个人都如此渴望找出答案。
You know, one of the appeals of a squirrel census is just the same appeal that has existed since the 1850s, which is it's clear to people that the world around them is not only inhabited by humans, that it is this multi-species place. And I think there is a need and a desire there to know something about your neighbors. The census is a form of appreciation, a way of recognizing that the squirrels are there, and that, in itself, is beautiful. Since we first broadcast this story, the 2018 Central Park Squirrel Census was released and they found 2,373 squirrels.
你知道，松鼠普查的吸引力之一与1850年代以来的吸引力相同，那就是人们清楚地认识到周围的世界不仅有人类居住，而且是一个多物种的地方。我认为人们有一种了解邻居的需求和愿望。普查是一种欣赏的形式，一种承认松鼠存在的方式，而这本身就很美。自从我们首次播出这个故事以来，2018年中央公园松鼠普查结果发布，他们发现了2373只松鼠。
In 2020, the Squirrel Census did another flash count of 24 other New York City parks and found an additional 433 squirrels. Those numbers sit perfectly in the middle of the range I imagined in such a way that I do not know if that seems like a lot of squirrels or very few. But I'm grateful we have the number nonetheless. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Caitlin Swaljay and edited by Joe Rosenberg, mixed by Sharif Youssef, music by Swan Rial, Jenny Conley, Nate Query, and John Neufeld. Special thanks to Susan Kirby and Andrew Christopher, whose interviews did not make it into this
2020年，松鼠普查项目对纽约市其他24个公园进行了另一次快速统计，又发现了433只松鼠。这些数字恰好处于我所设想范围的中间，以至于我不知道这算是松鼠很多还是很少。但无论如何，我很感激我们得到了这个数字。本周的《99% Invisible》由Caitlin Swaljay制作，Joe Rosenberg编辑，Sharif Youssef混音，音乐由Swan Rial、Jenny Conley、Nate Query和John Neufeld创作。特别感谢Susan Kirby和Andrew Christopher，他们的采访虽然没有出现在本期节目中，但没有他们的帮助，我们就无法完成这个故事。
episode, but without whose help, we could not have made this story. Cathy Tu is our executive producer, Kurt Kolstad is the digital director, Delaney Hall is our senior editor. The rest of the team includes Chris Barupe, Jason DeLeon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Martín González, Christopher Johnson, Bibian Lay, Lasha Madon, Gabriella Gladney, Kelly Prime, Jacob Maldonado-Medina,
Cathy Tu是我们的执行制片人，Kurt Kolstad是数字总监，Delaney Hall是我们的高级编辑。团队其他成员包括Chris Barupe、Jason DeLeon、Emmett Fitzgerald、Martín González、Christopher Johnson、Bibian Lay、Lasha Madon、Gabriella Gladney、Kelly Prime、Jacob Maldonado-Medina，
Sarah Bake, Nina Potuck, and me, Roman Mars. The 99% of his logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. We are part of the Stitcher and SiriusXM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building in beautiful Uptown, Oakland, California. Home to the Oakland Roots Soccer Club, of which I'm a proud community owner, other teams may come and go. But the Roots are Oakland first. Always.
Sarah Bake、Nina Potuck，以及我，Roman Mars。《99% Invisible》的标志由Stefan Lawrence设计。我们是Stitcher和SiriusXM播客家族的一员，现在总部位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心美丽的Pandora大楼，向北六个街区。这里是奥克兰根基足球俱乐部（Oakland Roots Soccer Club）的所在地，我很自豪能成为该俱乐部的社区所有者，其他球队可能会来来去去，但根基队永远是奥克兰的首选。
You can find us on all the usual social media sites, as well as our brand new Discord server. That's where I like to hang out. We talk about the Powerbroker, we talk about architecture, we talk about all kinds of things, movies, music. There's a link to that, as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在所有常见的社交媒体网站上找到我们，也可以加入我们全新的Discord服务器。那是我喜欢待的地方。我们讨论《权力掮客》（Powerbroker）、建筑，以及各种各样的事情，比如电影和音乐。在99PI.org网站上有相关链接，以及《99% Invisible》往期的每一集节目。本集目前还没有评论。点击文字记录中的任何句子即可发表评论。